Jesus said uh like they the Muslim says
when we say like Jesus is a peaceful
peaceful man he came for a peace
something like that then they say why he
bring sword yes that bring sword what
happened yeah and he Jesus say that slay
them in front of me oh that one Luke 19
oh are you kidding me they quoted that
to you yeah Luke 1927 this is Jesus they
told me here they quote this is what
they quoted to her poor lady okay Luke
do you love let me read it for you ready
Luke
19:27 but as for those enemies of mine
who will not let me
reain over
them bring them here and slay them
before me that's the one they quoted
right so Jesus said kill people okay now
let me show you the context are you
ready yes you sure
yes you
ready here's the context guys let's all
right now here here it is guys now let's
see what happens when we read the
context Luke 19
11-27 as they heard these
things he continued and told them a
parable it's a parable
sister you know what a parable is right
yes I know a story to illustrate a point
okay what's the point because he was
near Jerusalem so he's about to be
killed and then rise and go to heaven so
he's going to leave the world and
because they thought the king God would
immediately appear they thought he's
going to bring Heaven on Earth
immediately right therefore he
said a nobleman meaning a a
royalty Noble means someone who's who's
going to be royalty King went to a
distant country to receive a kingdom and
to return so he went to a far country
he's gonna get a kingdom he's gonna come
back Jesus is talking about himself he's
going to go to heaven he's going to be
crowned as king and eventually come back
to the Earth right amen but in the
meantime this what he does so Jesus is
now that man and we the Christians are
his servants so he called his 10
servants and he trusted to them 10
pounds and said to them trade until I
come you 10 here's 10 pounds make money
for me until I return from heaven now
the pounds are your gifts the gifts that
God has given you he's giving you gifts
and talents he wants you to use them
increase them for the glory of God right
yes now watch here but his
citizens those citizens that belong to
him because he's the king hated him he's
talking about the Jews who are going to
reject him and have him killed and sent
a delegation after him saying we do not
want this man to re over us he's talking
about the Jews they don't want him when
he returned okay this is now when he
returned returned from where
return from that's Jesus when he returns
returns from where from Heaven you got
it this is talking about the end time
yeah so it's talking about the second
coming when Jesus returns it's not
talking about now while he was on Earth
or us on Earth killing people it's
talking about when he comes from Heaven
he's going to judge and punish those who
don't believe in him
M when he returned having received the
kingdom he summoned these servants to
whom he had usted the money so now he's
going to deal with Christians we are his
servants he's gonna say come here you fa
you Sam what did you do with the gifts I
gave you did you use them and multiply
the kingdom or did you keep the gift to
yourself that he might know what
everyone gained by trading the first
came saying master your pound you gave
me a pound has made 10 pounds I
increased the to to nine more he said to
well done good servant because you have
been
faithful right and very little take
authority over 10 cities now I'm going
to make you ruler over 10 cities of mine
the second came saying master your pound
has made five pounds more right all
right so what happened to him now watch
you ready y now we're going to see what
the parable is because they like to you
right now watch here here goes let's
post it in pray for India you love India
I love India okay so here we go he said
and like man what happened here Master
he said to him come oh okay he said in
like manner you take authority over five
cities okay you you you increase it to
five five cities yours now watch then
another came saying
Master look here is your pound see the
pound you gave me I hit it I kept it
safe he didn't increase
it Joseph josea it refers to you ruling
the Earth ruling over the world because
when you come you're going to reign with
Jesus as kings and queens over the world
okay you take authority over five cities
then another said look master that pound
you gave me I hit it I kept it safe I
didn't lose it but he didn't increase it
which I've kept away put away in a
napkin for I
feared you I was afraid of you because
you are an exacting man you're demanding
you demand Justice and integrity you
collect what you do not deposit right
you collect from others because they
belong to you and you owe them and you
reap what you do not sow and you take
from their fields because it's all yours
now look what he says Jesus is talking
about the Christian who does nothing
with God's gifts so if you're a
Christian and you claim Jesus but do
nothing with the gifts and guys I hope
you're listening this is not only for
her it's for you and a warning to us God
has given all of us spiritual gifts if
we do nothing with those gifts the
Lord's going to rebuke us and punish us
because then we prove
Unfaithful he said to him out of your
own mouth will I judge you you Wicked
servant you knew that I was an exacting
man collecting what I did not deposit
reaping what I did not sow why then did
you not deposit my money in the bank at
least collect interest do something to
make it increase so that my coming when
I return see when I come back I might
have collected it with interest okay now
watch here I hope you're understanding
this it's for us now we get to the
finale so what is going to happen to
those Christians who claim to know Jesus
and follow Jesus but do nothing for
Jesus do nothing with the gifts he's
given us to increase the kingdom what is
he going to do to us okay watch here
here it
is then he said to those who stood by
take the pound from him this wicked
servant give it to the one who who
increased 10
pounds they said to master he has 10
pounds I tell you that everyone who has
will be given if you have God will give
you more see the principle guys the more
you do with the gifts of God the greater
your reward in heaven the greater reward
on earth when he returns guys are you
listening you listening too sister I
mean yeah he's promising the more you do
with the gifts I given you the more your
rewards the greater rewards when I
return to judge okay but from him who
has not from the one who didn't do
anything for my glory to advance my
kingdom to reach people and bring them
to
me even what he has will be taken away
from him wow yeah it's talking about
multiplying the kingdom it's talking
about advancing the kingdom building up
the kingdom with your gifts building
Believers up strengthening the church
leading people to Christ that's what
it's talking about see I tell you that
everyone who has will be given but from
him who has not even what he has will be
taken away from him now verse
27 now verse 27 but as for those those
people those Jews and others who didn't
want me to be their King who didn't want
to believe in me but as for those
enemies of mine who would not let me
Reign Over them who didn't want me to be
their King bring them here and slay them
before me so now sister let me ask you a
question let me ask
you when does Jesus have these people
killed now while he is on earth
now with the church or when he returns
from heaven I think when he returns from
Heaven saying you think why are you
thinking I think when he returned from
heaven in the second coming you think
only no is the Bible says so yeah in the
verse so you don't think you know it's
when he returns because he says when he
comes back yeah so when is he going to
slay his
enemies in the second coming you got it
when he returns to judge because he's
coming to judge the wicked and the
righteous so what are they using this
verse to prove what does it prove they
believe Jesus comes to judge they
believe God will judge the wicked and
Destroy them at the day of judgment
don't they yeah so what problem do they
have with Jesus coming on the day of
judgment to punish and destroy the
wicked who didn't believe in him what
are they talking about yeah because they
W compare him with mhammad maybe
what are you what were you saying I
didn't hear you because they won't
compare Jesus with Muhammad but this
passage buries Muhammed in hell where he
belongs right I mean yeah has nothing to
do with Jesus killing his enemies
now or when he was on Earth it's talking
about when he comes back from Heaven
returns to the Earth to judge the living
and the wicked yeah that's true so I
hope you got it but that's a warning for
all of us you and me and all Christians
Jesus is not warning us we Christians
we've been given gifts Jesus is saying I
expect you to use the gifts to multiply
the kingdom to increase the kingdom and
not be selfish and do nothing with it
because if you do nothing with it that
means you're Unfaithful and I will
punish you yeah that's true right yeah
so is that answer your question yeah Sam
thank you very much God bless you you
answer my question that's question